we all have ideas on our jobs more  shakeups at foxnews a longtime anchor  greta van susteren is leaving the  network  Greta addressed her departure on her  Facebook page revealing she made the  decision on Thursday night quote Fox has  not felt like home to me for a few years  and I took advantage of the clause in my  contract which allows me to leave now  the 62 year old says she loves her staff  colleagues the crews and viewers and  ended saying quote I hope to continue my  career in broadcasting we're all trying  to accomplish something a source inside  Fox tells ET that staffers are shocked  by crowd his exit and they found out the  same time the public did Greta's  announcement comes as news that gretchen  carlson settled her sexual harassment  suit with fox for a reported twenty  million dollars